انطلقت في تل ابيب وقفه تطالب بوقف الحرب
على غزه تنظم هذه الوقفه واحده من
المجموعات المناهضه للحرب هذه اللقطات
التي تشاهدونها هي لقطات مباشره من وسط
هذه المظاهره التي انطلقت في تل ابيب اذا
مطالبه بوقف الحرب على غزه وواضح ان هناك
اعتداء من جانب الشرطه على احد المتظاهرين
نجوان تقف في المشهد نجوان انت معنا الان
مباشره ضعنا في صوره ما الذي
يجري نعم ليلى بالفعل الان بدات الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بالاعتداء على عدد من
المشاركين في هذه الوقفه الاحتجاجيه
المطالبه بوقف الحرب على
غزه وكما تشاهدون هذا اعتقال لاحد الاشخاص
هفه في الحقيقه عدد عناصر الشرطه
الاسرائيليه اكبر من عدد المشاركين في هذه
الوه تديث عن الوقفه بشكل عام بخصوص هذا
المشارك الذي تم اعتقاله الان والذي
شاهدنا الشرطه تقده هل هناك
سبب لاعتقاله
وه اللي ا طلعتي على يعني هالسبب هل كان
هناك هتاف من نوع معين يختلف عن هتافات
الاخرين
مثلا نعم نعم مجرد انهم يحملون
لافتات تقول كفى للمجزر في غزه كفى للمجزر
دايلا تفخ هذا ما كانوا يرفعونه مباشره
الشرطه الاسرائيليه اعترضت هذه الوقفه
وطلبت منه يبتعد عن الموقع الذي تم تحديده
الذي تم تحديده للتجمع حاليا ايضا وائل
حاليا لحظه لحظه
لحظه حاليا ايضا يبعدون الصحفيين كما
تشاهدون نعم يعتدون على احد
الصحفيين دفع اذا يبعدون الصحفيين ويبعدون
ايضا المشاركين بهذه الوقفه ما ان بدات
عمليا هذه الوقفه في الموقع الت الذي تم
تحديده وائل الذي تم
تحديده في احد الشوارع المركزيه في تلبيب
ورغم ان العدد قليل جدا للمشاركين وهم
عباره عن افراد وجهات يساريه تطالب بوقف
حرب طلب منهم الانتقال الى موقع اخر بعيد
عن هذا الشارع المركزي في تل ابيب حيث
يتجمعون
بالعاده بداوا بالانتقال الى موقع اخر لكن
خلال انتقالهم بداوا يرددوا الشعارات
المناهضه للحرب ورفعوا لافتات كتب عليها
كفى لل المجزره في اشاره الى ال ال ما
يرتكبه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
غزه وحاليا ايضا يقومون بالهتاف ضد الشرطه
التي تتعامل معهم بعنف وترفض اي مثل هذه
التجمعات الشرطه كانت تخبرهم ايضا بان هذا
التجمع لا يوجد له تصريح رغم انه وفق
القوانين الاسرائيليه فان تجمع لغايه 50
شخص وحتى 100 شخص في بعض الاحيان لا يحتاج
الى تصريح من اجل التظاهر لذلك لم يطلبوا
تصريح من اجل التظاهر ومع ذلك تم فضهم
مباشره ما ان وصلوا وبداوا بالهتاف ضد
الحرب في غزه الاسبوع
منحها تصريح نعم قبل ان تكملي بمعنى ان
الاعداد التي خرجت اليوم كانت اقل يعني من
100 شخص ورغم ذلك تم ابعادهم وعدد افراد
الشرطه هل يعني يتناسب مع هذه المجموعه
[تصفيق]
الصغيره يعني كانت هناك اعداد كبيره لقوات
الشرطه الاسرائيليه رايناها حتى قبل وصول
المشاركين في هذه المظاهره قاموا
باحاطتها في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لكن
عنوان هذه المظاهره هو وقف الحرب على غزه
ووقف المجازر في غزه لذلك من الواضح ان
هذا لا يروق للشرطه الاسرائيليه بايعاز
بطبيعه الحال من وزير الامن القومي تمار
بن كبير الذي
حتى حتى وقت قريب فقط ق ليلى كان يمنع على
الاطلاق منذ بدايه هذه الحرب منذ اكثر من
ثلاثه اشهر تنظيم اي مظاهره لها علاقه
بالمطالبه بوقف الحرب رغم انها هناك عده
مظاهرات اخرى نظمت تحت عناوين اخرى لها
علاقه بالاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
غزه هناك بطبيعه الحال لا يستطيع منع مثل
هذه المظاهرات وهناك حتى مظاهرات كانت
تدعم عمليات الجيش الاسرائيلي في غزه وهذه
الح ولم يمنعها ب لكن منذ بدايه الحرب
يمنع حتى الداخل الفلسطيني حتى
الفلسطينيين في داخل الخط الاخضر منعوا
مرات عده متكرره وكانت هناك اعتقالات في
صفوفهم عندما قاموا بتنظيم بعض التظاهرات
في مدينه حيفا والناصره والان في تل ابيب
ايضا نرى بان هذا الحراك يمنع لمجرد انه
رفع لافتات تطالب بوقف الحرب ووقف العدوان
وصفوه المجازر استخدموا هذه الكلمه
والشرطه الاسرائيليه عناصر من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه قالت لهم لا نريد مثل هذه
اللافتات المحرضه ولا نريد هذا التجمع هنا
ولذلك يتم فض هذه التظاهر او هذه الوقفه
هناك ايضا كانت مظاهره اخرى قبل ايام وكان
وكانت قد حصلت على ترخيص من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه لكن في اللحظه الاخيره اعلنت
الشرطه بانها الغتها لحراك يسمى نق
نعم وتم يعني ايض تحويل هذه المظاهره
للاسبوع المقبل اشكرك جزيلا نجوان اذا
وسنتابع معك هذا هذه الوقفه